so it is
wonderful that for
us
we're able to recall
that the queen went in
that carriage
to
her coronation and also
she returned with the crown on and
either side of her she had a frame to
hold
the orb and also
she had a special
bracket so that the scepter could stand
as though she was holding it the whole
way long so beautiful isn't it it's the
third oldest surviving coach in the uk
after the speaker the house of commons
uh coach and also the lord mayor of
london's uh coach it's just so beautiful
as you said it's been re-guilted so many
times it's probably just gold now our
stuff
i'm very special for you joanna to
remember the little toy you had i know
and you know when i lost it i i said it
that i'd lost it and a fan
a fan sent me a little tiny replica of
it as a as a treasure to have
look at that
and you loved the windsor greys the
eight horses drawing the carriage
and it's many tons
it's medieval it's fairy tale this is
the whole point of it isn't it it's
something that is quite out of our ken
it's nothing to do with everyday life
this is something completely different
it's such a privilege to see it
look at the mall it's never looked
lovely empty of cars of course
and with the bracketing of the white
ensembles on these two
flagpoles it reminds you of exactly the
photographs that were taken of the
queen's carriage coming back at the end
of her coronation in exactly the same
format
and with the
tremendous care with which the armed
forces protect their sovereign and going
up walking the pace
and coming along behind this
carriage procession with the coach at
the center of it will come
representatives of first of all the
royal navy then the army and the athens
good to hear the music
[Music]
that the military parade is going to
represent all parts of the commonwealth
there will be representation of parts of
the commonwealth because there will be
the flags of the different nations too
being carried as part of that process
the lovely thing about crowds is they
react to almost anything and
if they've been waiting to be
entertained and something entertains
them it can
it can ripple along very very well
yeah the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall taking lessons
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as we hear diane namal the comments of
her majesty in the
address to the nation she made at the
end of her coronation we can see inside
the carriage
a representation of the queen as she
came back from her coronation wearing
the imperial state crown
and holding the scepter and the all
waving to those who are on either side
of the mouth it's a hologram that's been
created especially joanna it's pretty
cool so fantastic
and it's in black and white which makes
it even more
sort of eerily
thrilling in a funny way and to think
that the queen
maybe at windsor still is sitting and
seeing that
and she was 27 at the time she'd come to
the throne at 25
and all of us may have relations who are
at that age now and the thought that at
25
someone suddenly becomes head of state
carrying on at the death of her father
which itself was something she had to
come to terms with and then within two
years she's crowned
in a ceremony that is really the
the overcoming of the second world war
and its privations and this great
carriage represented a sense of hope
with the young queen and her young
husband